and we're going to begin in afghanistan
there's less than a week to go before
the deadline to complete evacuations but
the u.s is telling its citizens not to
go to the airport because of a security
threat it's urging americans already
there to leave panics growing among
thousands are still trying to get onto
flights more than 88 000 people have
been flown out of kabul by the us and
allied forces since the taliban's
takeover well let's speak to charlotte
ballas who's in kabul forest just bring
us up to date what the situation is like
at the airport following these warnings
yeah we're getting more threats uh
distributed around isil
different western countries putting out
alerts saying do not come to the airport
because the threat of an isil attack is
quite high the americans did put out a
threat of that nature earlier in the
week nothing has really eventuated after
that the taliban sent in their special
forces to secure the perimeter but still
western nations incredibly worried about
this actually telling their people not
to come to the airport we know about
1500 u.s passport holders remain in
kabul who are meant to be evacuated we
understand that they're starting to do
out of the wire if you will missions
where they they're sending helicopters
to try and retrieve these people and get
them to the airport because of these
threats the taliban also saying to us
you know we're also at threat trying to
secure the perimeter we're also at
threat to isil uh we also understand
that they've got a kind of new strategy
to get people in and we were witnessing
this yesterday where they're putting
people on buses essentially pre-vetting
them at different places around kabul
checking that they've got the paperwork
they need to get through and then taking
those buses as kind of a streamlined
process to get past the taliban that had
been working quite well yesterday but
then we understand last night that the
taliban started stopping some of those
buses on route to the airport and
checking people for documents there
whether or not some people said they
didn't get through after that but we
understand that the us and the taliban
have a deal where the taliban are under
strict instructions not to let anyone
through without a passport without a
green card without verified documents
and there's some confusion about what a
verified document looks like let's take
a quick look at part of the wider
situation in the last few days
particularly we've seen pictures from
people of people in afghanistan
struggling to get money out of atms and
from the banks and of course there is a
wider situation financially as well just
talk us through what the financial
situation looks like over the coming
days for people
i mean if you want to talk about a
crisis point at least in kabul the most
visual crisis point to the west is the
airport but for afghans the biggest
crisis point is money and the economy
and what is going to happen how is the
taliban going to run everything when
many western nations the imf the world
bank are starting to freeze funds on
them i mean as a day-to-day measure
prices of food have started going up
especially in the south uh the banks
have been closed for 10 days they only
opened yesterday but you could only get
out 400
the world bank said yesterday that they
are halting funding for all projects
because they're concerned about the
taliban takeover especially when it
comes to women's rights the problem with
that is that according to a number of
analysts they say that the world bank
actually covers about 30 percent of the
government's budget so that's teachers
salaries that's nurses that's the
taliban says you know world bank funds
run 2 300 small hospitals across
afghanistan if you freeze those funds
because you're concerned about women's
rights what does that actually mean for
people on the ground
who now are struggling to get access to
these type of basic resources
charlotte thank you very much indeed
that's charlotte bellas in kabul
turkeys have begun evacuating its
military personnel from kabul airport
the talibans reportedly asked for
technical help from ankara to run the
airport but it wants its troops out of
the country before the august 31st
deadline turkey has been part of nato's
mission in afghanistan and has hundreds
of troops stationed there
the u.n secretary general says all steps
are being taken to keep operations
running as afghanistan faces a mounting
humanitarian crisis the agency's
airlifted some staff from kabul to
kazakhstan but a temporary office has
been set up mike hanna's good more from
the united nations
the u.n says a third of its
international staff have now been
relocated from afghanistan to its
temporary base in kazakhstan in addition
it says a number of afghan nationals
have also been brought out of the
country though there are no specifics as
to the exact number
the staff have been told to work from
home unless it's necessary for them to
go into un offices to complete their
work
the u.n secretary general held what is
called as a virtual town hall with u.n
staff in the course of the day he is
said to have reassured them that the un
is doing everything it can to protect
their safety but he also says that it's
necessary for the un to carry on its
activities in afghanistan with a view to
the mounting humanitarian crisis
the u.n spokesman confirms that there
will be a substantial staff in country
but would not be drawn on the exact
number that is needed for the un to be
able to continue its operations
all of that is still being worked out
right we are
ongoing with a number of programs i
think we've talked about wfp unicef unh
cr
uh who
obviously as the situation stabilizes uh
we will have a better idea of
what we're able to do what the
humanitarian needs are and what the
staffing is will be that we need to run
those programs and most importantly the
funding that we will need to run those
programs
there have been a number of reports
about discontent among un staff about
the lack of action in terms of
protecting their safety
the un spokesman refuses to comment on
the specific allegations but he did
confirm that a number of letters have
been received from various unions which
are being considered by the secretariat